[Music]
we're looking to cleanse the community
you wouldn't want to be the old man out
in the street
you talk to my family and i'll kill you
did you spend quite a while just really
agonizing about how you were going to
tell this story
about 50 years that's how long i spent
it was really a long time deciding
whether there was a way in which it
could come out that could you reach
other people basically i didn't want to
just be staring at my own navel making a
film like this it wasn't personal
therapy it was really to see whether you
could find the story of a family in a
difficult situation where humor and all
the other
coping mechanisms we come up with to try
and deal with difficult times could
speak to other people and this lockdown
promoted that uh i think because the
introspection and the
feeling unsettled that we we've all
shared really drove me back to that time
i mean it's such a traumatic thing to
have witnessed at a young age do you
ever
get past that i'd say the legacy of
personality for me was a guardedness you
know was a a you know a desire to escape
i think i escaped into acting you know
if i want to be an amateur psychologist
about it and i found other ways of being
you know because uh some inbuilt fear
that being who you were or saying the
wrong thing at the wrong time was going
to bring sort of more catastrophic
change coming back to this film i think
was was to try and sort of embody a
simple message of of uh without being
too hippy-dippy about it that you can be
who you are and who you are probably
doesn't change a great deal in the in
the center of it but you can cover it up
sometimes this film was about revealing
that to me and in so doing maybe
allowing other people to recognize parts
of their youth that are still with them
and then they might positively access do
you think perhaps those who grew up
witnessing violence and the troubles do
you think the prime minister has taken
for granted i guess how important it is
that the public have trust
the northern ireland situation is so
complex in my generation i'm 61 years
old now for
to have experienced peace up to nine
years old in my case and then see what
happened for the following 30 years and
3 700 deaths later and then to
understand and appreciate however
imperfect and it is
the process that was achieved through
the good friday agreement of 98
is to understand how every single day
not only trust has to be won but the
peace has to be won
and and the two things are interrelated
lest we forget it is easy in the busy
noise and cacophony of the contemporary
world where instant reactions to
everything are required and instant
justifications and all the rest of it
that we
take a moment this film in my creative
life represents taking a moment to uh
appreciate that the wee girl still
showing some interest yeah
she looks to me sometimes but we're not
allowed to talk in the class so i can't
say anything and then we go out to the
playground she always goes off with the
other girls i know you absolutely did
not write this with awards in mind but
but people are mentioning oscars they're
mentioning baftas
does it matter is that something you
even want to think about
it's certainly not why you joined as it
were but you're thrilled these days
anything that gets anybody into a cinema
i'd say thank you very much so to even
be part of that conversation is uh
exciting but really the most exciting
thing the fact that we made a film that
we loved were proud of and people were
responding to and it opens this week
that's exciting anything else that's
that's gravy